foreign
beings have or have ever had is they're
the smartest beings on the planet but
soon that will not be true in fact like
next week so when AI becomes stronger
than we are what do you do exactly and
what does it mean for democracy we asked
Elon Musk about contingency plans for
dealing with Advanced general
intelligence here's part of that
conversation
[Music]
you've heard people say we should just
blow up the server Farms because there's
no way that once if this gets rolling
there's no way to slow it down
what do you think of that
well the the really heavy duty
intelligence is not going to be
distributed all over the place it'll be
in a limited number of server centers if
you say like very like very sort of deep
AI heavy duty AI it's not um
it's not going to be in your laptop or
your phone it's it's going to be in you
know a situation where there's like a
hundred thousand uh really powerful
computers working together in a service
center so it's not so so it's not like
subtle and they're they're a limited
number of places where that can happen
in fact you could if you could just you
can just look at the heat signature from
space yeah and it'll be very obvious I'm
not suggesting we go and blow up to
service centers right now but
there may be some it may be wise to have
some sort of contingency plan where the
government's got an ability to shut down
shut down power to these uh server
centers like uh
you don't have to blow it up you can
just cut the power
um
and what would cut connectivity as well
that's another way right yeah but what
would trip that switch do you think in
your mind what would be the threshold
that you'd have to pass to
warrant the government cutting off your
power or cutting off your signal
well I mean I guess if we lost control
of some super AI
um like for some reason like the things
that would normally work to do a passive
shutdown like the administrator
passwords if they somehow stop working
where we can't uh slow down or or
you know
I'm not sure I don't have a precise
answer but if there's something that
we're concerned about
um
and and uh and are unable to stop it
with with the software commands then
uh we'll probably want to have some kind
of Hardware both switch yes I think you
know cat hurt
have you talked to since you know Larry
Page and you obviously you know the
opening guys because you started
definitely have one have you talk to the
the people who run these two the biggest
AI companies about this recently
I haven't talked to Larry Page in a few
years because he got very upset with me
about openai
uh so when when opening eye was created
uh
it did it did shift things into it from
unipolar world where Google Google do
you mind controlled uh
you know like I said three quarters full
AI Talent two where there's now a sort
of uh
bipolar world or open Ai and Google
deepmind and their
uh and now we're at least it seems
opening eyes maybe ahead
um
so uh so I have had conversations with
the open AI team timelman I haven't
talked to Larry Page because he doesn't
want to talk to me anymore for a few
years
can I ask you this about since you've
been around a lot of this the thinking
so why would anyone not be a specist be
human-centered in his thinking about
technology like what's the thinking
there I think what he's trying to say is
that
um
if I were to guess uh that he that all
Consciousness should be treated equally
and whether that is digital or
biological
hmm
and you disagree
I disagree yeah
[Laughter]
especially if the digital uh
Consciousness or whatever you want to
call digital intelligence decides to
curtail the biological intelligence
right so you're just building your own
slave master and why would you do that
doesn't sound great
yeah
yeah I mean
we shouldn't we we should at least no
need to rush you know like what's the
hurry
where's the fire
how well what I mean tell us about the
hurry so this for I know you've been
talking about this for years and on the
sort of the periphery of our attention
we've heard Elon Musk talking about AI
but for most people it's been like three
months since they've had any interaction
with this at all
um so what's the timeline here at what
point does it start to really change our
society do you think
I think it starts to have a probably
an impact this year a gpd4 now it's like
writing poetry
um and pretty decent poetry actually
pretty decent yeah it's a skillet
rhyming is incredible yes yes and it's
coherent yes it is uh it's you've got a
narrative like yeah that's right yeah
so you could say it's hard to do like
most humans can't do that that's true so
it's already past the point of what most
humans can do most humans cannot write
as well as uh chat gbt
um
and they certainly and no human can
write that well that fast as an
investment knowledge so maybe
Shakespeare how can you have a democracy
with technology like that
I mean if democracy is you know
government by the people each person's
vote is equal to every other person's
vote I mean and people are choosing
their votes freely
can you have a democracy with this
well that's why I raise the concern of
um AI being a significant influence in
elections
um and and even if you say that AI
doesn't have agency well it's very
likely that people will use the AIA
um as a tool in elections
um and then
you know if AI is smart enough
are they using the tool or is the tool
using them
so I think things are getting weird and
they're getting weird fast
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight